この仏教という まあブッダの教えっていうのは
あの あまり知られていないかもしれませんんですけど
まあちょっと普通の世の中にある宗教とはあの
いろいろ点で違うところはたくさんあるんです
似ているところあるというより
やっぱり違うところなんですね
たくさんあるのは それまあ
一番違うところは この智慧に語っているということなんですね
で 人間一般的には智慧と知識というものをすごい嫌がるんです
感情と欲だけで生きてきたがるんですよ
ですから お釈迦様は智慧に語るとすごく嫌がるんです
智慧っていうのは やっぱりあの
作るためには まああとまあ一応知識というものも
まあいくらかは役に立ちます
知識なくてもすごい鋭い智慧がある人々はいましたけどね
今も まあ人を調べてみると
いることは確かにいるんですよ
まあ知識とかはないんですけど
智慧はあると うん で まあ知識はまあかなりあの間違っているもの情報なんですけど
知識を得る時は一つこの頭の中も働くんですね
で 頭ちゃんと働くと まあその分だけはいいんですよ
頭働いているというところは
知識は別にそんなに役に立つということではないんです
で それでこの頭っていうのは
まあちゃんと働いてこないと
智慧っていうのは生まれてこない
働いて疲れちゃうと智慧が生まれてこないんですね
頭が働いてすごく元気になって
頭がリラックスしてもらわないと
智慧っていうのは出てこない
まあですから この普通に頭働くということは
ただもう妄想するだけでね
まあ回転するだけで それで結構疲れちゃうんです
脳も疲れちゃうんです
ですから 妄想して考えているんだっていうことで智慧が出てくるかというと
そうでもないんですね
ですから 難しいのは頭を働いてほしいんだけど
くだらない余計なことを考えてもほしくないという
もうどうにもならないやり方なんですよ
我々にとっては頭を使うということを考えることなんです
頭をいっぱい使ってくださいと
どう考えてもいけませんと言っちゃうと
成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
どうすればいいんですかと
何も考えないということは
もうただボケーっとしていることだから
頭を使ってないことなんですね
まあですから この確認作業というね
考える必要ない仕事をさせているんですよ
考える必要は全くない
でもすごい忙しい仕事
まあ確認しなさいって言っちゃうと
もうあることあること
もういくら確認したっても
もうもう終わりがないほどものすごい大量のデータっていうのは体に触れちゃうんですね
その体に触れるデータをもう全てできるだけもう明確に確認しておく
それで普通のもうどんな知識人よりもものすごい頭を使わなくてはいけないことになるんですよ
頭を使うと頭すごい回転して活発になってくると
もうかなり人間っていうのはものすごい不思議に元気になるんですね
ものすごく明るくなる
体もすごい活発になってくるんです
ですから このそこはこの瞑想の状況をね
テストする基準の一つでもありますね
まあ元気に明るくなっているんでしょうかと
でも別に理由はないんです
本人が別に理由は知らないですけど
すごい気楽に生きていられるという
で 鋭く物事を見えるとかね
暗くならないと で 少々でもね
ほんの少々の実践でも
やっぱりそれでもって元気になるならばね
頭がなんとなくすごくこのリラックス状態になって
まあ悶々と色んなものは考えないことになってしまって
すごい気楽になりますね
で それだけじゃなくて
まあ鋭く物事を見えるとかね
分かるとかね で 体の体調も
まあ体調もどんどん良くなってくるというならば
まあヴィパッサナーの実践は一応うまくいってるんだっていうことになるんです
で 暗くなっていくんだったら
まあこれはうまくいってないということ
で よく見えることで瞑想すればするほど我が強くなって
排他的になって頑固になるということもあるんですね
それはまあ瞑想していないんですね
まあただの不善心を育てているだけのことになるんです
うん ですから 性格で 仕草でと言うんでしょうか
この体の動きでまあ大体わかりますね
うまくいってるかいないかっていうことは
はい で そこでこの初めて瞑想する方々
気をつけてほしいのは
瞑想を始めたら なんかこのどんどん心が落ち込んでくるんではないかと
面白くなく 面白 何でしたっけ？つまらなくなってくるんではないかと
ということがあるんですよ
それはもう一度も頭使ったことがないだからなんです
使おうとすると もうやめると
で 体使ったことがない人が
なんか体使う仕事なんかにいきなりさせちゃうとどうなりますか？いきなり疲れて休んじゃうんですね
普段普通こそこそと動いていた人なんですけど
じゃあ山でも登ってみようとかね
穴でも掘ってみようかとかね
何か大仕事をやりましょうと言っちゃうと
始まるんですよ じゃあやりましょうと
始まってすぐもう疲れたとかね
腰が痛い 足が痛いとかね
言って全く何もしないで休んでしまっちゃうんですね
体の場合は大体そういうことで
それでその人がまあ普段私はそんな怠け者じゃないよと
まあ日常生活するんではもうちゃんとやることはやってるんだよとは言いたがるんですよ
言いたがるんだけど まあ結局あまり使ってないんだから
体をね 疲れて何もできない状態に陥ってしまう
同じこと心にもあります
普段全く心使ってない人が瞑想しようと実践しようとしちゃうと
いきなり心がまあ止まってしまう
それであるのは落ち込みとつまらないと
もうだるいと で  [笑い]眠いとかね
そういうことが出てきます
それでまあ道が二つありますけどね
やめるか それでもこそこそとやるかというね
大体九十パーセントの人々はやめると
勇気がないんですね やってみようというね
大体はまあやめて まあまあいろいろ他のごまかしをする
瞑想しようとしている
置いといて 本読んだり
あっちこっち見たりとかね
そうやってまた頭が使わないことにするんです
本読んだら頭が使っていると思ったらそれは大違いです
それは頭を使っていることじゃないんです
それで休んで古い古い回転に戻ってしまうんですね
ですから そういう人 戻った人にとっては
たまたま瞑想したっても
ただきついだけの嫌な仕事になる
まだやるかと 体の体力と同じなんですよ
ある日 重労働させちゃって
体が筋肉がすごい痛くて
もうどうにもならなかったと
それでまたゆっくり体を動かすことにして
普通に寝たり ご飯食べたりした
で またもう一度やりましょうと言ったら
もうまだやるかと という気持ちになるんですよ
この間やって本当に嫌でしたとかね
修行の場合も同じことで
この一旦やめて普通のまた妄想の世界に戻っちゃうと
まだやるとすごいきつい仕事になります
ですから 一般的には人っていうのはそんなに頭使うってことない
本当にこの才能 能力ある人っていうのは
もう 1万人に一人でも見つからないぐらいないんですよ
いないんですよ ですから
普通みんな他の普通の人々なんですね
ですから 誰にでも瞑想を始めようとしたら
必ず出てくる問題っていうのは
体がだるい 足が痛い 背中が痛いとかね
もう体調が崩れるとか
で 眠くなるとかね もう教室に座らなくなるとかね
そういうことはもう確実に出てきます
ですから 続ける続けるっていうのは
やっぱり考えないで確認するっていうことは
やることね 考えないでやることだから楽だよと
言って その仕事はもう決してやめないで続けることなんですね
座っててできないと思ったら他のことでやればいいんです
体には常に情報が触れていますよ
で 座っていて瞑想するっていうこと
それは瞑想であって ヴィパッサナー実践ということというのはちょっと言いにくいんですけどね
体に触れる情報を見なさいというのは
それで自害意識が生まれてくるんだからね
論理的にはお釈迦様の方法はそういう方法なんです
我々は色んなことを考えたり感じたりするのは
体に情報が触れるんだからなんですね
その情報を観察しなさいよと
ですから 立っていたっても
歩いてたっても どっちでもいいんです
まあ瞑想にならないのは
喋ったりする時と本読んだりする時とかね
瞑想にはならないんですね
それはどちらでも妄想するための仕事なんですね
ですから その二つやめて
体に触れる情報だけ観察していくと
それでこの頭がまた回転し始めるんです
それであの知識の世界ではなくて
あの智慧の世界が現れてくると思います
お釈迦様は知識にはいっぱい語りましたけどね
論理に 知識に 人間の知識にいっぱいお話はしたんだけども
まあ知識能力のあまりにも少ないんだから
これがなかなかわからないんですね
ですから 欲張って じゃあ勉強してやりますと思ってもね
なんかそんな能力あるかなという疑問も出てきます
だから早い方がいらんことを勉強する
仏教のことについてもね
勉強するよりは やっぱり実践してみて
自分で経験してみた方が早いんですよ
[背景音楽]実践していくと知恵が出てきます
その分に必要な仏教の論理はすごい簡単に教えてあげることはできます
これはこういうことですよと
実践しないで理解しようとするのは
もうこれは本当はとんでもない話なんです
もうすごいそれ高慢で言うことなんですよ
それでお釈迦様がこの悟ってからは
まあこういう言葉を言ってるんですね
アディガトーコーミャーヤンダンモサントーパニートアタッカーワチャローニピニプノーパンディタヴェーダニーヨーという
で 私は真理を体験しましたと
ニプノーっていうのはものすごいこの完成しているというかね
パーフェクトというか
すごい知恵の真理を発見しましたと
パンディタヴェーダニーヨー
これは一般の人に理解できない
パンディタっていうのは賢者っていうことですよ
賢者のみ理解できるんですよと
まああまりにも難しいんだからね
アタッカーワチャロー
人間の理屈には合わないんだと
人間すぎて理屈ね ガンビーロ
ものすごい深いんだよと
ドゥッダソ 一般の人々にはもう発見しにくいと
ドゥラーボードーっていう言葉があります
大変理解しにくいんだよと
ではそれだけで人間の知識はお釈迦様が一応もうゴミ扱いしているんです
わかるわけないんだよと
でも自分がものすごく苦労して
ものすごいもう命かけて修行したんだからね
それ発見したんだから
それからね まあ説法しようとしたところで
お釈迦様が諦めちゃってね
こんなの語る必要がないんだと
で またもったいないんだからね
まあ大変こんな真理知ってる人間一人がいて
これ誰にも教えてあげないで死んじゃうとね
これは大変もったいないことだから
話しましょうということにはしたんですね
あそこで自分のお世話までしてくれたこの 5人の比丘たちに話すことにしましたし
その時はお釈迦様がやっぱりまあとにかく話してみたんですよ
それを話してみた時はものすごい難しい
尊い語ったわけでもなくて
すごくわかりやすく一応話してみたんです
その時話したのは このこの一般的にはね
みんなにだいたい あまり大事な教えではないと思っているこの四聖諦ですよ
4つの真理なんですね
それはもう後の仏教の人々は平気でバカにするんですね
そんな沙門に教える教えでレベル低いよとかね
というだけで 何一つレベル高い教えは後の人々は持ってないんですけどね
だから自分がわからないんだからけなちゃうというやり方で
いろいろ仏教は宗派に分かれて
あの狐の話がありますね
ブドウを食べようと思って飛んではみたんだけど
なかなかブドウのところに届かないんですね
その物語ご存知だと思いますけど
イソップの物語の中にありますね
これはインドにもある物語ですけどね
美味しいブドウをキツネがブドウ食べるんですかね
よくストーリー作りますけど
食べないと思いますけど
ジャコウって言うんですからね
まあキツネとはちょっと種類が違いますけど
美味しいブドウを見て
じゃあこれ食べてやるぞと
飛ぶは飛ぶは飛ぶはもう届かないんですね
それでなんだこんな失敗
酸っぱいブドウ誰が食うんですかと言って開き直って帰るんですね
かっこつけて ですから
これ今ことわざになっていてね
で Sour grapes って英語のことわざにもなってましてね
自分にできないことを批判したら
まあ英語でもすぐ言うんです It
is sour grape for you.と言っちゃえば
もうみんなわかるんですね
意味が じゃああんたかっこつけてるだけでわからないでしょと
そういうふうにこの仏教ではいろいろ宗派が出てきたんですけど
で 誰一人ブッダの教えを壊すことはできなかったんですよ
その とにかく問題はこのお釈迦様がこの四聖諦を 4つの真理
苦集滅道というね それ教える時でも
いつでもこの「プッペ アナヌッス テース ダンメース チャックン ウドパーディ」今まで聞いたことがない真理に対して 「
チャックン ウドパーディ」目が覚めましたと目が現れましたと 「
ニャーナン ウドパーディ」
ニャーナンというのは智慧ですね
智慧が現れました 「パンニャー ウドパーディ」
パンニャーもまた智慧なんですね
言葉 2つ使って 「プッペ アナヌッス テース ダンメース チャックン ウドパーディ ニャーナン ウドパーディ パンニャー ウドパーディ」
智慧が現れます それから最後に「アーローコ ウドパーディ」
光が現れましたと いわゆる今まで真理が知らなかったことは暗闇で真理が発見して来たことが
まあアーローコ 光が現れましたと
ですから この みんなこの考えてでも頭脳細胞をやっぱりこの奮い立たさす
立たすとと言うんですか
やっぱり回転してほしいんですよ
妄想で回転するんではなくて
もっと知識的にすごいインテリ的に頭を使ってみればいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
ですから その経典を見てみると 「
イダン ドゥッカン ティコ プッペ アナヌッス テース ダンメース」
これはドゥッカであると
いまだ聞かなかった いまだ発見できなかった真理に
私には智慧が現れましたと
目が覚めましたと 光が現れましたと
それで私たちから見れば
お釈迦様はドゥッカ説明するんですよ
ドゥッカって何でしょうかと 「
タトラ カタマン ビックウェ ドゥッカン アリエサッチャン」
ドゥッカっていうのは何でしょうかと 「
ジャーティピ ドゥッカ」
生まれることは苦であると 「
ジャラーピ ドゥッカ」
老いることは苦であると
ヴィャーディピ・ドゥッコ
病はドゥッカ 苦しみであると
マラナンピ・ドゥッカン
死ぬことも苦しみであると
生老病死です 四苦でしょうに
それからアッピエーヒ・サンパヨーゴ・ドゥッコ
えっと あれ 何でしょうかね
嫌なものとね 付き合うことはドゥッ
苦しみであると ピエーヒ・ヴィッパヨーゴ・ドゥッコ
好きなものから離れることは苦しみでしょうと
ヤンピッチャン・ネラベティ・タンピ・ドゥッカン
自分が期待するもの 希望するもの
欲しがるもの 得られないときも
またそれも苦しみですよと
それでまたもう一つセットで教えるんですよ
サンキッテーナ まとめて言えば
ひいて言えば パンチャ・ウパーダーナ・カンダ・ドゥッカ
この体そのものが 心と体もそういう方ですよ
それを五つに分けているんです
体 物体は色蘊と言いますね
体で感じるものが この痛いとかね
楽しみとか それは受蘊と言いますね
それからこの概念とかね
知識とかね そういうふうに固まっているものは
あの サンニャ 想蘊というんですね
想っていうのは思いという感じだと思うんですね
思いますというね 考えるという意味の
それから我々はすごい感情もかなり持ってますよ
大量にいろんな感情がね
まあ皆様方 あんまり感情って何なのかわからないかもしれませんですけどね
結構あります で 欲は感情で
怒りは感情で まあそれぐらいわかると思いますけど
まだいろいろあるんですよ
で そういう大量の感情は
まあそれはサンカーラと行
ぎょ 行蘊と呼ぶんですね
それからこの認識する機能
知る機能 見える 聞こえる
味わうとかね その単純な知る機能が識蘊と
そうやってこの五つに分けているんです
ですから 物体は一つと
心は 心の働きが四つに分けているんです
分けてあって まあひいて言えば
この体そのものが まあドゥッカであると
それが いまだ勝ってない真理だよと
それが私が初めて発見した真理だよと
というと みんな あ なんだという感じになるんですね
あれ 頭が悪い証拠なんです
チャレンジしてみないと
それがそんなにも大胆な真理ですかと
欲しいものは得られないことが苦しいだよというのは
そんなにも大胆な真理ですかね
革命的な人類に発見できなかったお釈迦様をお釈迦様に悟りを引き起こした真理ですかね
どう思いますかね だからそこら辺
そういう風に考えていただくならば
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことにちょっとチャレンジしてみる
で もうチャレンジもインテリ的にチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それわからないんですね
ほとんど ただ自分の主観で馬鹿にしてやるぞというぐらいしたら
チャレンジでもなんでもないんです
チャレンジっていうのは
やっぱり人が言ってることは何なのかと
本当にその通りでしょうかと
厳密に研究してみることなんですね
科学者がやることなんですね
今 現代 我々生きている世界ででもインテリの人はチャレンジするんですよ
例えばどこかであの新しい科学何か的なものを発見しましたと言っちゃうと Nature
やらサイエンスなんとかとか雑誌ありますね
アカデミックな科学 あの
なんとか雑誌ありますね
そちらに発表するでしょう
で 発表しちゃうと もういろんな日本の科学者たちも
自分たちの研究室でこそこそとそれをまたやってみるんですよ
あれが本物のチャレンジなんですよ
ただ なんであの人がそんなこと言ったって誰が認めるもんかと
そんなことはありえないというふうに言わないんでしょ
科学者は そこでイギリスで発見したら
アメリカの各大学でもそれはやってみる
フランスでもやってみる
それで日本でもやってみると
同じことをやってデータが違うんだったら違いますよと発表するし
データが正しければその通りだよと発表する
この最近発見したっていうのは何でしょうかね
あれどんな国でしたっけ？このこの日本でずっと研究してますね
あの あれ あの何でしょうかね
あの超伝導とか何とかってね
まあまあ 初めはまあ妄想的な思考ですけど
それやれば大変楽で便利だよということで
まあ一所懸命研究をする
それで あの絶対温度ででは
まあ超伝導機能は果たしちゃうんですよ 200
ぐらいになっちゃうと
ですから 永久的に 例えばその温度で何か回しておくと
それは永久的に回す でも温度が上がっちゃうと
もう超伝導能力消えちゃうんですね
だから商売になりません
だってものはずっと液体窒素の中で置いておくわけにはいきませんから
それでずっと研究しているんですね
やっぱりものすごい苦労して
ちょっと温度を上げてみる
ちょっと温度を上げてみるとかね
で なんとかこの普通のルームテンパレチャーで超伝導能力を発揮する物質を作ることできたんだぞというね
まあ一応科学雑誌に記事が出て
で いきなり出たんだから
まあよくわからないということで
で たまたまそういう発表あったんですよ
あったんだけど それはまあ後で調べると勘違いでということになったんですね
で 今度はまあ勘違いというよりは
まだまだ日本の発表はまだまだ情報とね
あまりわからないんですから
まあちょっと実験を試す
試すことはちょっとできないんだと
ですから 科学の世界では
そういう風に何か言ったらみんなチャレンジしてみる
あれは嫌で憎しみで馬鹿にするためにやることじゃないんですよ
本当にインテリなんですよ
言ったことは本当かと
自分の実験室でも試してみるという
で ブッダの教えはブッダもものすごいもうインテリの究極的なインテリ的な教えですからね
そうやってチャレンジしてほしいがあるんですよ
だから信仰は置いておくんですね
チャレンジしなさいよと
それで人間っていうのはチャレンジの仕方がわからなくて
ただまあくだらんことを言って批判するだけで
そんなことはチャレンジでもなんでもないんです
それで この 五蘊はドゥッカでしょうと
ドゥッカっていうのは苦ですね
苦しみっていうことで
生老病死はドゥッカでしょうと
言ったことは なんでお釈迦様が
そんなに大発見だと教えるんでしょうかね
おっしゃるんでしょうかね
じゃあチャレンジしてみてください
すごい常識で聞こえるでしょ
すごい当たり前 嫌な人と一緒に生活すること
これはもう嫌でしょうしね
そんな当たり前のこと
すごい好きな人から別れちゃうとね
ものすごい悲しむんでしょうね
そんなこと当たり前じゃないかと
そこはお釈迦様の智慧の鋭さなんですよ
すごい当たり前のことで話す
話してもうちょっとチャレンジをしておく
これがわかって 私が一切の苦しみから解放されましたと
心は完全に汚れから消えましたと
真理を発見しましたと
今ひとかけらも苦しみがないんだよと
そことあの教えと合わないんですよ
病気になることは苦しみだよと言って
これがわかって 私がもう悟りましたよと言っちゃうと合わないでしょ
地球はこれぐらい重いですよと言ったら
みんなびっくりしますけどね
すごい人でしょう 地球の重さまで測ったんだからとかね
科学者はそういうことをやってますけどね
地球の重さ 太陽の重さとかね
それで我々はびっくり
すばる望遠鏡で何かそこら辺にある何か写真を撮ったら
びっくりとみんな やっぱりすごいというのは普通ですけど
そうじゃなくて ごく普通なことを言って
これがびっくりする真理だよというと
ね すごいこの頭を使かって仏教を勉強するならば
ここら辺でなんでなんかちょっと理屈合わないんではないかと
病気になること嫌だなとか
年取ることを嫌だな こんな当たり前のことでしょうと
これ知って悟れる 何なのかと
そこでお釈迦様がチャレンジかけてます
みんなに だから誰にでもあることでしょ
実験できますね 生老病死やら愛別する苦やら
怨憎会苦やらね で 期待するもの
欲しがるもの 得られない苦やら
いつでも自分の人生だからね
これ実験室はあります
本当にチャレンジする人が真理わかるんですよ
それで全部苦しみから心も解放します
だから頭を動かしてほしいということなんです
私が言いたいのは 瞑想することよりも
ものすごく生き生きして元気になって修行してほしい
なんか落ち込んで落ち込んで
もうドロドロドロドロ
子供も暗くなってっていうのもやめた方がいいんで
それだったらね だから仏教ってのはものすごい活発的な教えなんです
すごいインテリ的なんですよ
ものすごい鋭い それはものすごく誤解してね
まあいろいろ私がずっとこの日本の社会っていうのはね
知識の社会と思ってね
すごいまあ力強く喋ってはいたんだけどね
結局はもうかっこつけるだけでわかってないんですね
わかってないところは
まあじゃあわかるように喋りますよと
聞いてみてくださいと言っても
結局聞くこともしないんですよ
こちらにはどんな方法でも喋れますけどね
子供にも喋ります 大人にも喋れます
どんなインテリな人でも喋ります
方法変えるだけ で 聞いてみるっていうこともしない
伺う 質問するっていうことをね
で その代わりにものすごい私はまあめちゃくちゃ批判しているんではないかとかね
と まあ批判には聞こえるんですよ
言う 喋ると それも私も認めます
ちょっと力入れて仏教を語ろうと思っちゃうと
なんかもうもうと むちゃくちゃ批判してるんではないかなと
でもそういうことを言ってると
私は本当は笑ってるんですよね
別に批判してるのも 別に怒ってもう嫌になってってるわけじゃないんですよ
激しく批判することはものすごい楽しくて
明るくて言ってることなんですけどね
で あの 人間期待している話っていうのは
おだてる話なんです なんて素晴らしい人間でしょうとかね
で おだてる話ではは人騙しなんです
あなたは立派な方ですと
素晴らしいと で 日本で人気ある教えっていうのはね
たくさんあるしね 日本でもあるし
外国からも来るし そのどんな話でもおだてる話だったらもう人気爆発と
で 例えば西洋人でもたまたまでも日本でも批判しちゃったら
ものすごいそれにはもう攻撃する
褒めたらもうまあすごい人気
だからもう外国人はよくそれ知っていて
で だから日本人が外国から来る有名人
誰でもね インタビューするときは一番最初にあなたの感想は何ですか？とかね
日本に日本にも入ったばっかりなんですけど
感想を聞く その聞かれる相手がね
頭いい人だったらね 黙っていなさい
いい加減にしなさいよと
それは聞いたばっかりだからね
何も知りませんよと 感想
感想と言ったって これから日本の社会を見て帰るとき感想を言いますよと
でも誰もそう言わないでしょうに
なんて素晴らしいんでしょうかと
みんなすごい親切で優しくて礼儀正しくとかね
で 次に じゃあ日本の食べ物はどうですか？とかね
こっちが思ってるんです
日本の食べ物は一番美味しい食べ物やと
思って ああ すごい最高ですよと向こうは言う
それで万々歳で その人の歌を買う
その人の踊りを見ると
その人の本を買うという
もう何なのかと この生き方っていうのは
私はもう言いたくはなっちゃうんですよ
それで永久的に我々の知恵がもう理解能力
知恵のところを置いておいてね
もう変わりませんよ 日本食は世界一だと言いながら
みんなむちゃくちゃフランス料理やらね
それで値段高いことに祝ること
あんな食うんですかね
体にも悪いフランス料理なんかは
だから実際に見ると 日本人が中華料理も大好きで
フランス料理も大好きで
もう毎日でもフランス料理を食べれるんだったらなんて幸せかと思うなのに
外国人から聞いて ああ
私は納豆好きです 豆腐好きですと言ったら
そうですねとか やっぱり日本の料理がと
で 本人も食べないんですよ
本人も焼肉食ってるんです
だからやっぱり観察っていうのはそういう風にした方がより私はこのおだてる論理は良くないということの例として出しただけなんですよ
おだてちゃうと我々にはもう何にもあの追加的なものがなくなっちゃうんですね
ああそう 私は良かったんですかって
それで終わっちゃうんですよ
そのまんまで終わっちゃうんですね
だから金儲けに来る人々にとっては
別に何か教えてあげる必要はないんですよ
他に現代人の金儲けっていうのは機嫌を取っていくらか奪って逃げるという
別に必要なものをしてあげて
その労働力の分いただくという仕事は今ないんでしょうに
だから今の現代経済っていうのは奪う
騙して奪うと だから作る品物っていうのは全て必要でない品物
必要な必要がない品物を作って
宣伝 宣伝して 何とかしてもう買ってもらうという
ですから この商売に来る人々にとっては機嫌を取っただけで十分ですね
自分の目的は達しますよ
そちらに慈しみがないんです
慈しみがあるということは
やっぱり何か教えてあげる
何か弱いところを直してあげるというね
間違っているところはもうちゃんと言うということなんですね
そうすると言う人は損しません
批判も受けます だからかなり危険なことなんです
だから 世の中で本当は日本が一番仏教が語りにくい世界なんですよ
ものすごい覚悟を決めて
心の中であるんだから我々は完璧だという
と言いながら 完璧だったらいいんですけど
文化的にも何でも行ってあげればいいのに
フランスの種 フランスのブランド製品でないとカッコつかないんですね
日本のものはもう嫌 ダサい
これで完璧でしょうかね
だからここら辺はちょっと論理のね
合わないというところがあるんです
別にヘリックス的なとこっていうのはどんな人間にもありますから
それはそんなに問題はないんだけど
やっぱりそのどんな人間でも自分のアホらしさに気づいてほしいんですよ
それは嫌なものじゃないんで
見てみればかなり笑えますよ
だから ある人に私が言ったんで
自分で笑えないんだったらダメですよと
自分のおらかさに それは堂々と言って
それに笑わないとね 人格できてないんですよ
ですから このそこら辺あればね
大変ありがたいことで
我々ももうどんな人間でもね
無茶なところはあります
変なところあります まるっきり論理をもう合理的でもなんでもない
もうもう愚痴なこともしますよ
でそれそれに自分には自分で笑えますかと
人にあの指を刺される前に自分で発見して
私がこんなことやっちゃったんだから
こんなひどい目に遭いましたよとかね
なんてアホかと それと自分のことに笑えるというね
それがあればね 大変明るいんですよ
だからこの基本的に思考はね
そうやって直さなくちゃいかんところいっぱいありますから
まあ私にとってはものすごいやりにくい仕事にはそこまで直す必要あるんでしょうかと
ただ真理だけ語ればね
説法だけすればいいところで
やっぱり人格までもう余計なところまで喋らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それでものすごいもう嫌われるばっかりで
いくら嫌われても こちらは一向に気にしないという
まあ頑固な態度でいます
よく言われますよ で それね
私はそれなりにもう またもう批判してほしくないということで言われちゃうと
結果として結局 100倍 100倍になるだけ
一つだけ批判して もうそれで終わるはずなのに
それを直してあげようと
この人の言葉を言って
親切に言ったところで
もう 100倍になっちゃうんです
で こちらも好きでやってるわけじゃないんですよ
本当に純粋に仏教だけ語ってればね
大変自分にとっても気持ち大変気持ちよろしいしね
頭も疲れないしね 仏教だけだったら私は別に苦労しないんですけど
でも いろんなことを勉強しなくちゃいけないんですよ
あれはもう出家としても大変きついことなんです
ある清浄会の坊さんに対して
私はすごい感動してたんですよ
1980年代に一つの小さな本を書いたんですよ
あの本がもうアメリカ世界社会で
仏教の人々の間ではもう人気爆発で
誰でも読む あれは完璧にアメリカ人に語ったんです
サティの実践方法という
アメリカ人以外誰が読んでもあまりあの英語をちょっとわからないと思いますけどね
で タイトルもマインドフルネスインシンプル ENGLISH
シンプル ENGLISH と思った途端
我々は子供でも一人ぐらいの英語だと思っちゃう
とんでもないんです アメリカ人が日常の中で
このもういわゆる公ではなくて
裏で喋っている英語で書いてるんです
だから アメリカ人にとってはシンプル ENGLISH なんです
我々日本人にとってはもうとてつもない難しいんですよ
でも それを読みながら
私は考えたのは このお坊さんがもうものすごいもう 70歳も飛んでますよ
学者ですけど もうずっとアメリカに住んでるしね
でも出家でしょうに アメリカ社会の隅から隅まで入り込んで
この人々の思考 文化 言葉の使い方
隅から隅まで入り込んで
淡々と語るということは
これ大難しかっただろうと思います
一行一行にどれぐらい苦労したんでしょうかと
でも抜群に明確に書いている
一つそれの経典に引用してないんです
引用してないんだけど
もう博士もアメリカ大学で博士を取ったんですけどね
まあインドでもね まあ勉強してて
随分伝道歴史は古いんですよね
ずっともう伝道活動だけやってたお坊さんです
まあ厳しいんですけどね
まあちょっと下手なこと僕が言ったってすっごい怒鳴っちゃいますけど
厳密に仏典にテキストに沿って書いてるんです
でも誰にも気がつかない
それで平気で言うんですよ
あんた方はね いろいろ仏典やらね
学問的なことやらね 知りたければいっぱい本があります
読みなさい 読みなさい
いっぱい本がありますから
で これは単なる HOW TO という本ですよと
だからまあ そこを見ても
まあ自分の勉強の良くなる勉強にもなりましたけど
この文化のことをね 隅から隅まで知るっていうことがね
これ大変な仕事ですよ
皆様方にとっては何のこともないかもしれませんだけどね
私は誰の家にも呼ばれたことはないし
まるっきり別室に一人で生活しているし
それの日本の社会のね
まあ全部調べなくちゃいけないし
でも誰もドアを開けてはくれません
心のドアも玄関のドアもあっち行けという
だからまあ大変きついというかね
この研究するっていうことをね
まあとにかくこの 私たち仏教を語る場合は
おだては難しいんですよ
人間の生き方がそれで正しければ
仏教を語る必要もないんです
人間悟ってるんだったら仏教を語る必要もないんです
だからちょっと聞くと
まあなんで我々褒めてくれないかとかね
という気持ちにはまあちょっとなってしまっちゃうんですね
まあまあ そういうことで
この仏教は勉強するためにやっぱり何か必要かというと
やっぱりこのすごいこのじりじりと頭を使うこと
すごいインテリ的になること
試してみること チャレンジしてみることっていうのは必要なんです
そうすると頭が動いてきます
頭が動いてくると 自分たちの自分のアホらしさにも気づくし
社会のアホらしさにも何のことなく気づくんですよ
で 気づいて それに笑うくらい笑えるぐらいね
勇気が出てきたら 自分の心を直すっていうことはできるんですね
だから笑えなきゃダメなんですよ
自分のこの 何て言いますか
みっともないところとかね
未熟なところとかね いい加減なところとかね
いろいろあるでしょうね
それにはもう何のことなく笑っちゃうと
自分で自分のことをバカにするということなんですよ
それぐらいインテリにならないと理解できないということになるんです
ですから またチャレンジはまた思い出してあげますけど
そんな人が病気になったら苦しいって当たり前でしょうに
そんなことで悟れますかね
なんでそんな単純シンプルなことで
語るんでしょうかね  [笑い]あれほど単純に言っているのにわかってないでしょ
結局は だから難しいんです
結局は人生は苦しみであるということをさえもわかってないんです
わかろうとしないんです
頭から違いますと と思っているんです
それを発見してほしいんですよ
だからあまりにもバカバカらしいんですよ
ずっとあるのを目の前に毎日あるのは苦しみなんですけど
それを否定する 違います
そんな馬鹿なこと世の中で人間にはね
あり得るんでしょうかね
だから答えは私はあまり出たくないんですけど
ちょっと頭回転させてみてください
よくよく頭を使ってチャレンジしてみてください
チャレンジっていうのは
この科学者のチャレンジですよ
世の中で言っている意味のチャレンジではないんです
科学者も悔しいんですよ
どこかで何か先に発明か発見しちゃうと
同じ分野の科学者ってすごい悔しがるんですよ
悔しがってもしょうがないんです
それで自分たちもチャレンジしてみるんで
同じ実験をして 一つは宗教
まあ一応ちょっとヒントだけ教えます
宗教の世界からで 私は別に批判はしたくないんですけど
したくないので批判します
別に怖い人はいませんだから
例えば宗教何語ってますかというと
逆を語っているんですよ
素晴らしいと 生は最高やと
セカンドライフというね
生きることですね これマーベラス
エクセレント ビューティ
英語の単語だったらそういう言葉使っています
ほんまであります ビューティーオブライフ
どんな日本語訳でいいんでしょうかね
ビューティって言えば美ですかね
おしゃれして美しく生きることじゃないんですよ
生きること自体 生命の美しさという
宗教はそれ語っているんです
なんて素晴らしい命ですかと
なんて尊い命ですかと
では 世界にあるすべての宗教を調べてみてください
素晴らしいですよと言うんであって
これがあるゆえに素晴らしいですよと
こういうこういう理屈で
こういうこういう論理で素晴らしいですよと
この単純な証拠でも出してますかと
調べてください イスラム教でもキリスト教でもどんな宗教でも
日本でも宗教いっぱいあるでしょう
天台とかね 真言とかね
みんなもう生まれつき悟ってるんだよと
言った途端ビューティーオブライフ語ってますよ
なんて素晴らしいですかと
じゃあ証拠を出せと私が言いたいんですよ
好き勝手なことを無責任に言うんじゃないんですよ
で 見てみるとみんな好き勝手で言うだけ
ですからこのみんな事実語ってないんですよ
はっきり言うと お釈迦様以前にもたくさん宗教ありましたし
誰一人事実語ってない
頭がちょっとおかしい
上が聖典に書いているんだから
ハチミツ美味しいですよという考え方ですよ
だけど インドの世界から言えば
インド人がもうカースト制を作っちゃったんですね
カースト制を作っちゃって
ヴェーダ聖典に書くんです
好き勝手に 神様の口からバラモンカーストとか
腕からはシャトリアカーストとかね
太ももからはワイシャカーストだと
足の裏からシュードラカーストやと
それで神のある部品で生まれたっていうことに証拠になるんですかね
ただ 世の中にあるカースト制度にいい加減な聖書を書いただけでしょうに
そんなにヴェーダ聖典が神の言葉であるならば
じゃあ日本人の社会はどうやって神が説明するんですか？ないでしょうに
ヴェーダ聖典 日本人のこと書いてない
モンゴロイド系の人間に対して書いてないんだから
ただアーリア系のインド人のことだけしか書いてないでしょうに
だったらそれ神の言葉になるんですかね
神が人類を創ったならば
ニグロイドの人々やら高ケシエンというアーリア系の人々やら
モンゴロイド系という皆様方とかいるでしょうに
全部書かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
ただ 自分の周りに見た情報だけ見て
それに特許を取ろうとする人ができているものに
よくも特許を取ろうとするという
このヘリクスの状況っていうのはね
私たちはこのちょっと思考を動かしてくださいというポイントであって
別に他の目的で喋ってるわけじゃないんです
インテリ的に物事を考えてくださいと
だから そういう風にあるものを見て
例えば女がどうしても男にすがると
どこを見てもそれ見えるんですね
それで神はそういうふうに作ったんだろうと特許を取るんですよ
それで神に裏切った 神を裏切ったんだから
女の人が子供を産むのはきつい仕事であるならば
なんで動物も同じ苦しみに合うんですかね
特許を取るんだったらいい加減に
だから動物見たでしょうに
そんなことを書いた人々が
聖典書いた人々が 家畜動物でもいたでしょうに
人の痛みわからないんですよ
犬も猫も牛も馬も ものすごい苦しんで子供産むんですよ
馬がどんな悪いことしたんですかね
じゃあ人間が アダムとイブがね
悪いことをしたんだと言うならば
じゃあそれを置いておきましょう
馬が？牛が？野生の動物知らなくても
なんでそんなに苦しむんですかね
だから今飼ってる牛とか馬とかね
あまりにも贅沢に飼ってるんだから
この筋肉ができてないんですよ
赤ちゃんを産むときは
それで飼ってる人々はこのワイヤーで引っ張るんでしょうに
牛を産まれる時でも 行ってみてください
日本でもいくらでもいますから
その時は牛がもう倒れて苦しいんで
もうもう体ぼよんぼよん状態だから力がないんですよ
死んじゃいます それでさっさと獣医さんやらみんな走ってきて
もう手を中に入れて もうワイヤーで引っ張るんです
あれ 牛にとって超気持ちいいと思いますかね
だから苦しみっていうのは
子供の時は誰にでも同じくあるんですよ
それが見えない それであの
産むことはいかに苦しいかというと
アメーバにさえ苦しいんですよ
これは一番最近の あの
発見です だと思いますけど
日本の新聞でとか出たかどうかちょっとわかりません
あの アメーバっていうのは単細胞でしょ
あの分裂して2つになる
あれも大変きついみたいです
そこで私が読んだ科学記事であったのは
あのミッドワイフっていうのはお産婦ですか
この助産婦 で アメーバも助産婦を飼うんだとという面白おかしく書いてあったんですよ
ミッドワイフヘルプアメーバインプロクリエーションというタイトルであった
もうだからあまりにも面白くて
もうタイトルはすごい面白くてね
まあそれでずっと読んでみたんですけどね
で あの科学記事だからね
アメーバにもいろいろ種類がたくさんあります
それでこの あの 核が分かれますけど
分離するんだけど この細胞が離れなくなっちゃうんだと
細胞が離れなくなく離れなくなると
この細胞の外の膜からある化学信号を出すんだと
化学物質出すんですね
その化学物質が出てきたら
他のアメーバたちがそれにすっと寄ってきて
押さえてあげるんだと
押してあげちゃうと別れちゃうんだと
だからこれ あの まあ面白おかしく書いてるんだから
このもう化学物質で泣くんだと
シグナル出すんだと 出したら他のアメーバたちが寄ってくるんだ
それがさらに本当かとわかるために
その別な皿ビーカーで
その化学物質を取り出して
ほんのちょっと入れちゃうと
別のアメーバがお産して揺れるわけじゃないんで
他のアメーバがサッとそれ呼んで寄ってくるんですね
やっぱりアメーバたちにしても大変だ
助けなくちゃあかんという人間の言葉にすればね
だから考えてみれば アメーバにさえも
これきつい仕事なんですよ
でも特許を取ってないんです
聖書が 世の中にある各宗教の聖書は
人間だけ 私は常識と言いたいんですけどね
そのポイントから考えてみたっても
みんな我々の謳っているのは
よく子供作って金儲けて
神を賛嘆して死ねば天国にまでいて楽になるんだという話です
だから楽だ楽だという話ですよ
結果として頭の悪いラクダになって終わるだけなんです
だからお釈迦様の教えは革命的なんです
こうだよと お釈迦様は特許は全部取ってるんです
すべての生命が神々まとめてみんなこうであろうと
お釈迦様 ちゃんと特許を取ってます
でも人間だけ インド人だけではないんです
一切の生命に対して生きることは苦しみですよ
じゃあ嘘か真か調べてみてください
生きることは誰に楽ですか？と
一切の生命に対して苦しみですよ
アメーバにしてもウイルスにしても
我々の体に入ってね 細菌やらウイルスやら我々病気作るでしょ
あれ楽だと思いますか？ウイルスにとっては
あまりにも危険でしょうに
体の中に入っちゃうと
もう細胞が出てきて もう攻撃して殺すでしょうに
やっとあっちこっちで逃げた隠れたウイルスはもう何とかして繁殖して
もう風邪引くなりにもう勘弁するなりに何とかするんだから
今人気あるエイズウイルスっていうのはものすごい臆病者で
で 随分隠れて あれはちょっと空気に触れただけでも死ぬ
ものすごい弱い 他のウイルスと違って
だから臆病者だから自分を食べられちゃいますからね T
細胞に 白血球に とにかく白血球の中に入っちゃうんです
自分を食べる前に 白血球も食べることしかしませんだから
食べて分解するんだから
自分で入っちゃうと白血球は別に攻撃しないんですね
それで白血球をもう破壊してしまう
それで免疫機能がなくなっちゃいますから
人が死んじゃいますけどね
別にエイズウイルスが別に体に何の病気も作りません
風邪も引きません 熱も出ません
ただ白血球食われるだけ
それで他の病気で死ぬと
すごい弱いんですよ でも我々にまだ治療方法もないんですね
一旦うつったら まあそれで時計見て待つしか方法ないんですね
ですから 大変だよということは
ウイルスにさえ大変なんですよ
皆様 ちょっと考え方変えてほしい
ウイルスと言った途端
敵扱いではなくて ウイルスの立場になって考えてください
この体に入ったらいかに攻撃されるかと
ですから 生きることは大変だよというブッダの真理は
じゃあ変えて できれば変えてみてください
お釈迦様は一部の特許を取ってないんです
全部まとめて特許を取ってます
だから この真理は神々
人間 すべての生命に対して真理だよと
だからすごい真理なんですよ
嘘やといくら踏ん張っても言えないんです
だからお釈迦様悟り開くんですよ
何にもとらわることは故にないんだと
こうですから 天国に行ってみよ
なんとバカなことですか
天国に行ったらすごい大変なんですよ
どこにも楽なところないんです
[咳]だから生が苦であると分かったら
もう天国にも行きたくなくなっちゃうし
それで生きていきたいという希望があるんだから生きているでしょうしと
だから苦しみが続くでしょうし
いや 別にその欲望も消えちゃうかと
ですから このドゥッカダヨーと一番目の真理はっていうのは
これは一番目の真理であって
すべての人間の考え方に対してお釈迦様は攻撃しているんです
科学者の思考にも 政治家の思考にも
経済学者の思考にも 哲学者にも
宗教家にも 全部くだらない考え方だと
人間の苦しみ増やすだけですよと
だからこれが出世間の真理だよと
政治家が一生懸命研究して我々の苦しみが増す増す
経済の能力ある人々は一生懸命考えて研究して
人間の苦しみを増やす
宗教哲学もとにかく苦しみを増やすという
なんで増やそうかと すごい勘違いしているんです
生きることは大変楽だと
一向に楽になりません
どんな建物を作っても
どんな乗り物を作っても
楽になりません なんで生老病死云々とかいたんですかというと
それもどんな生命にも同じことなんです
そういうふうにできているんだよと
そこで人間の道はすごい変で
この見る限り見る限り不満
見る限り苦しみ そうするとどこかに楽しみがあるんだぞと
と思うところは理屈崩れているんです
だから見る限り見る限り苦しみだったら
普通の人だったら ああ見た見たものは何だかんだでも苦しみでしたよと結論するんですけど
これ変な科学者たちで
楽しみがあるんだ どこですかね
だから海に落ちたならば
まあ水ですけど 全部塩味水なんですね
それで飲もうと飲もうとするんだけど
飲めない それでやっぱりどこかに真水がありますよと思うこと自体おかしいんですよ
ではなくて もう見渡す限り塩ですよと言った方が正しいなのに
だから我々にはもうこの約束の地というね
変な概念が頭にあるんです Promised
landって英語でよく人気のある言葉なんです
約束してるんですよ エイダンという
どこか神様が見たこともない神様の約束
また信じるんだからね
だから逆になんで人間がこの天国みたいな
あるいはエデンみたいな
この約束の土地を妄想したんですかね
結局生きること苦しみだからでしょうね
そんなに楽だったら約束の土地がいらんでしょう
そこでもちょっと理屈が崩れているんですね
だからブッダが希望期待しているのは
この論理的に明確になってください
それは必要ですよと そこら辺は知識でも理解できます
すごい厳密にインテリ的に物事を考える
部屋を 部屋を調べれば調べるほどゴミが出るんだったら
この部屋にゴミがあるんだろうと決めればいいんですよ
どこかに宝物があるはずですよというのはもういい加減なんですよ
だから妄想はいらん 仏教には体験するその瞬間
瞬間のことを観察してみれば
一時間に時間ぐらい瞑想したら
何を我々確認するんでしょうかと
それは置いておいて やっぱりどこかに約束の地があるんだよとかね
調べると苦しみはさらに増えるだけです
[咳]だからちゃんと客観的に観察してみてください
瞬間瞬間で観察してみてくださいと
そうすると真理が発見できますよと
真理っていうのは今ここにあるものであって
あの世にあるものじゃないんです
まあそのように考えると
いくらかね 頭が動いてくるだろうと思います
別に批判として取るのではなくて
もっと頭を回転してほしい
大胆に考えてほしい 事実を客観的に見てほしい
事実だったらどんどん堂々とそれを認める
知ると語ると で そんなことする人々は変人だと世界は言う
気にする必要ないんです
時々子供たちがいますね
本当に生まれつき知恵を持っていて
すごい大胆なことを言っちゃう
大人がみんなすごい気持ち悪がっちゃうんですね
変な子やと でも子供は汚染されてないんだから
正直に言う 観察したことをそのまま言う
本当すごく合ってます
我々大人の世界から見れば変人ですね
だからそこら辺もまた私たちにとっては便利になっています
我々は変人になりたくない
だから愚か者になる みんな思うことを思う
みんな言うことを言う
みんなやることをやる
じゃあみんな正しいんですかね？みんな悟ってるんですかね
今までずっとこういう風にやってきたんだから
もうやめませんというふうな
そういうのは仏教 仏典では激しく批判しているんです
変人でいいんです そういうちょっとあの
そこら辺で頭を回転させてみてください
そうすると瞑想はいくらかうまくいきます
話はそこら辺終了します
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます